تقع دبي في مدينتك العالمية المتوسطة ،
فهي مكان حيوي غني
بالثقافة وغارق في التاريخ ، وعلى الرغم من أنها
قد تشتهر بالعجائب المعمارية ، إلا
أن المدينة تكملها مجموعة من
المناظر الطبيعية للحياة البرية والعجائب الطبيعية ،
ما يميزها هو العديد من
المفاجآت غير المتوقعة
يعطينا الموقع الأول لمحة
عن تاريخ المدينة وبداياتها
كمركز تجاري مزدهر يقع في
المناظر الطبيعية الصحراوية الرائعة ،
وبالتالي فإن موقع Aruch Al Hadeed الأثري
هو أحد أكثر الاكتشافات إثارة
في القرن الحادي والعشرين ، ويعتبر الموقع
مركزًا  من
تجارة الاستيطان البشري المستمرة
والتعدين التي يعود تاريخها إلى أكثر من 3000 عام
إلى العصر الحديدي القطع الأثرية الفريدة التي تم
اكتشافها في الموقع معروضة للجمهور
في المتحف الحي الوحيد في العالم ،
وبالتالي يتيح متحف آثار الحديد
للزوار التعمق في
قصة التجارة الصاخبة  الطرق بين
بعض أكثر
الحضارات تأثيرًا يتم تحديثها بانتظام في
القطع الأثرية الموجودة في المتحف  تشتمل على
رؤوس فأس وخناجر
ومجوهرات معدنية وحجرية من بينها
خاتم ذهبي معقد عمره 4000 عام والذي
ألهم شعار معرض إكسبو 2020 الشهير ،
غرفة السينما ثلاثية الأبعاد تنقل الزوار
إلى حافة الصحراء لمعرفة المزيد
عن بعض الاكتشافات الرائعة
[موسيقى]
مكاننا التالي هو موطن لمجموعة كبيرة ومتنوعة
من المساكن المصقولة بالريش
داخل مدينة دبي الصاخبة ، حيث
ستجد كنزًا دفينًا من
حياة الطيور المتنوعة في الأراضي الرطبة الشاسعة لمحمية
Russell الأساسية للحياة البرية المعروفة
باسم رأس الخور  وهي تضم مجموعة
متنوعة من المسطحات الملحية وأشجار المنغروف
والبحيرات الطبيعية التي تعد واحدة من
المناطق الحضرية القليلة المحمية في المنطقة من
واحدة من مخابئ الطيور الثلاثة التي يمكنك
مشاهدة أكثر من 25000
طائر مقيم ومهاجر والتي تشمل
البلشون العظيم طائر الغاق الشعاب المرجانية وأكثر من
ذلك  النجوم الحقيقية للعرض هي
طيور الفلامنجو الوردية التي توافدت على
المنطقة خلال فصل الشتاء للمساعدة في
جذب رفيقة
يجلس عليها تلسكوب لايكا  تختبئ أشجار المانغروف على
الحافة الجنوبية للملاذ
لمشاهدة الطيور الجارحة المهيبة والنسور الكبيرة المرقطة وهي
تحلق في جولات مصحوبة بمرشدين
تأخذ الزوار في رحلة لاستكشاف
الأراضي الرطبة من خلال أعين أحد
دعاة الحفاظ على البيئة
.  تقع على الساحل
على بعد مسافة قصيرة من
شواطئ دبي المتلألئة مغامرة بحرية غير معروفة ، حيث
كانت مياه الزمرد للخليج
معروفة في يوم من الأيام بالغوص بحثًا عن اللؤلؤ في
تجارة مزدحمة بأكثر من 500 نوع من
الحياة المائية تعيش في
المياه الدافئة البكر المحيطة بدبي هذه المياه
هي موطن  العديد من الأسرار السحرية
للعالم تحت الماء ، أحد أكثر
مواقع الغوص شهرة يقع على عمق 30 مترًا
، سفينة زينب التي يبلغ طولها 70 مترًا لتهريب النفط
والمتجهة إلى آسيا هي
موقع حطام عميق مثير للغواصين المتقدمين في المياه المفتوحة
ومن بين حطام السفن الأخرى المثيرة للاهتمام
الشيخ  محمد بارج نبتون 6
والنجم المنتصر حيث يمكن للغواصين
استكشاف المزيد من الألغاز التي تضيء
بعمق
أدناه  توجه إلى الصحراء لاكتشاف
الحياة البرية المتنوعة التي تزدهر في واحدة
من أكبر محميات الحفظ في
المنطقة على بعد نصف ساعة فقط من دبي
وتمتد على أكثر من 40 هكتارًا من
أراضي الشجيرات الصحراوية الهادئة والأراضي الرطبة
، تعد محمية المأمون موطنًا لأكثر من
200 نوع من  الطيور المحلية اسم Mar
moom مستوحى من أحد أكثر
سكانها احترامًا ، الحبارى Jabara ، وهو
نوع من الطيور المحمية دوليًا
والتي اعتمدت عليها الحضارات البدوية بشكل
كبير للبقاء على قيد الحياة في الصحاري العربية.
أعلى
تجمع لطيور النحام الكبيرة في
بيئة صحراوية وواحدة من
أكبر قطعان الغزال العربي في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
، تأخذ تجربة بدو المأمون
الزوار في مغامرة تاريخية
لاكتشاف كيف كانت الحياة في القرن التاسع
عندما اجتاز البدو الرحل
الصحاري التي يمكن للزوار  استمتع
بالعروض الثقافية وعرض الصقور
والمأكولات الإماراتية اللذيذة في سورو
استدركت بعظمة الكثبان الصحراوية وأخيرًا
نسافر عبر الصحراء في
ظلام الليل لتجربة عجائب
علم الفلك الإسلامي
منذ آلاف السنين للتنقل عبر
الكثبان الرملية الشاسعة وقد استخدم قدامى المحاربين في دبي
تقنية تتضمن الشمس والنجوم
بدلاً من  البوصلة يستخدمون ظلالهم الخاصة
بالإضافة إلى الكثبان الرملية التي
شكلتها الرياح لاجتياز
الصحراء بسبب المناظر الطبيعية المتغيرة باستمرار ، حيث
كانت غالبية رحلاتهم
تتم بالليل عندما
تضيء النجوم السماء مما يجعلها مصدرًا أكثر
موثوقية للملاحة.  لا يزال دور
علم الفلك الإسلامي ، خاصة من
القرن التاسع إلى القرن الثالث عشر ، يؤثر على
الملاحة الحديثة اليوم
، ولا تزال هذه التقنيات والقصص القديمة مشتركة
في دبي من جبال حتا
إلى كثبان المأمون ،
حكايات ساحرة للراقص أراكيس
والنسر الطائر ألتاي إير  ليست سوى عدد
قليل من الأشخاص الذين استقروا ودعوا هذه الأساطير تنقلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]